House Democrats now are weighing their
next steps after Moeller statement his
words put more pressure on house speaky
Speaker Nancy Pelosi to start an
impeachment inquiry but Pelosi says we
still don't have all the facts Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy the
Democratic Party had been split on the
issue of impeachment
are they still still deeply split Tony
but there were some new converts to the
impeach camp yesterday after Muller
spoke they viewed his remarks as
essentially at him tossing the ball
Congress's way and saying it's time for
Congress to act Nancy Pelosi however
speaking in San Francisco made it clear
that she still prefers to wait she said
that it is important for Congress to
build its own airtight case before
resorting to impeachment proceedings
because otherwise it's doomed to fail in
the republican-controlled Senate the
House Intelligence Committee has
recently worked out a deal with the
Department of Justice to get its hands
on some of that previously redacted
material from the Muller report so once
they are able to get a look at that that
could help determine where Congress goes
from here Nancy
mr. Muller made it very clear yesterday
that he hoped his remarks would be those
remarks would be his last Nancy Pelosi
as we heard wants him to testify what
are the chances of that actually
happening
well the negotiations are ongoing he had
indicated that if he was going to
testify he'd prefer to do most of it
behind closed doors Democrats obviously
prefer the spectacle of him testifying
in an open setting because they believe
that every time he talks about the
president lying or talks about
obstruction of justice it just helps
them to build their case all right Nancy
thank you